des images qui nous ramène quelques
années en arrière maintenant vous vous
souvenez sans doute de la série dallas
avec jr sue ellen et bobby ewing et bien
25 ans après les voici en chair et en os
les héros de la série sont à paris pour
promouvoir une vente de vêtements au
profit des enfants malades
françois jullien pieds-noirs virginie
travers l'univers impitoyable est avant
et ils sont presque tous venus 29 ans
après le premier épisode mettre aux
enchères leurs costumes pour la bonne
cause
il y a le méchant jr aujourd'hui 75 ans
le gentil bobby toujours élégant l'uci
et son sourire comment dirais-je enfin
bref passons et bien entendu sue ellen
alcoolique et malheureuse dans la série
aujourd'hui ravis on est une femme qu'on
se connaît pendant trois cent cinquante
six épisodes et devant plus de 300
millions de téléspectateurs ils ont
porté chemises vestes de cowboy et
santiags le costume de leur vie au joli
tee shirt et en les seules fois où bobby
portait un chapeau s'était acheté le
reste du temps il était comme moi en
moins raisonnable
et puis j'ai essayé de poser une
question patriarche de la famille il
faudrait que vous parliez plus fort
j'entends mal joseph heureusement bobby
vient à son secours
le monsieur te demande ce que tu as fait
tes vêtements j'ai pas le temps de
parler de ça maintenant chéri il faut
que j'aille par le bétail
aujourd'hui ces acteurs jouent les
seconds rôles dans des séries ou des
films
ce soir ils font oeuvre de charité en
vendant leurs costumes quelques milliers
d'euros une goutte de pétrole comparé au
million de dollars brassée par la
famille ewing
allez allez allez on l'apprend